next guest became a viral sensation on
tick-tock
for breaking into someone's home but
it's not what you're thinking because
we're not advocating that here he didn't
actually take anything from the house
not even a little
but he did leave it spotless after
spending two and a half hours cleaning
it from top to bottom yeah i know this
is such a wild story check this out
so
my friend tells me that one of his
co-workers wants me to clean his
apartment so i go there today
and
he tells me that there's a key under the
map get the key go into the apartment
clean the entire apartment so he calls
me and he's like yo where are you and i
was like um i'm in your living room
waiting for you to walk in i'm playing
with your cat
he goes
uh man
i don't have a cat
what
so comes to find out that i cleaned the
wrong apartment and broke in and cleaned
somebody's random apartment
you're welcome
please say hello to louie angelino
so how did this happen so i was off by
one digit it was only one number
227 instead of 277. um
and i had just assumed that i was going
to the right address
um but it just so happened that
there was two keys under both of the
mats which is insane
because what are the odds that there's
going to be two keys
on the same time in the same day
under both mats
how did you even get into the taking
care of people's homes um
to be completely honest with everything
that happened with kovid i was feeling
very like uninspired and um
she's in the audience right now my best
friend joe duran's mom and my mother are
in the office
that is them they are the ones that my
mom ever since i was a kid has always
told me clean room clean mind and diana
who looks so lovely today
um
told me she came up with the idea to pay
me like 50 bucks a week to just to keep
the apartment clean for
for her and and my best friend and
started out with that
and through doing that i would just you
know i would go in there with my
bluetooth speaker and i'm jamming out
and i'm dancing and i'm swiffering and
i'm having so much fun i don't even
realize that i'm cleaning i was at a
very dark place and at that time i
didn't have a car i didn't have a job i
really didn't have a purpose and they
gave me that thank you guys so much for
giving that type of advice
and direction and being such positive
influences
and i want to celebrate things like this
in the world and you know you have this
new passion and you're going to pursue
this as a career i would love to that
would be the dream all right well i know
that you started a gofundme page to help
kick start your cleaning career and
you're giving and your altruism and
you're taking care of people and we just
want to help you continue that and
foster that um so our friends at safely
are giving you ten thousand dollars
worth
of
and that is not only a year's worth of
supplies but we'd love to feature you on
our website and help build your business
oh my god
[Applause]
you already did oh girl oh my god
you already did thank you so much it's
really a big thing for my mental health
and like that's one thing i wanted to
mention is that i know everybody
somehow someway battles with something
that goes on up here and if something is
keeping a clean environment
can help
somebody like me with mental health it
can help out somebody else too
and and that's just that's so important
for me because mental health
really finally i think we're at a point
where it's being taken seriously yeah i
think athletes talking about it is
really amazing because
if they're saying they struggle
i i think there's a lack of bias
sometimes or maybe a greater openness to
understanding that even the strongest
people go through it
but i think we also need to hear from
everybody about how important that
mission is i mean i see you building a
whole business that also recruits other
people like let's get this going louie
all right let's go all right let's go
thank you louie go on the drewberrymart
show.com to learn more about louise
amazing business and thank you for
safely giving ten thousand dollars to
louie's cause
[Music]
you